The history books are filled with colorful characters and Eddie Chapman was
definitely one of the brightest. He could be called many things, rogue,
scoundrel, conman, cheery unrepented criminal,
and even maybe secret agent desperate times call for desperate measures.
The old saying goes and the dark days of world war II were definitely desperate
time.
Had Chapman been living, working and stealing at any other time in history,
he may have found governments and military agencies,
and those who regularly arrested him to be much less lenient than they were it.
Wasn't the source to be trusted with anything yet British intelligence did trust
him. And so did the Germans and it's here that we,
the word trusting rather loosely.
One of the military intelligence agents who worked with Chapman was left talent,
Colonel Robin tin, I Stevens,
and it's worth setting the scene with his thoughts on one of his most
unpredictable agents. He wrote,
I do not wish to be held wanting in admiration of a brave man,
but must issue a about this strange character,
where do the loyalties of Chapman lie? Personally?
I think they are in fine balance. Desperate times, indeed.
Eddie Chapman was born in England on November the 16th, 1914,
and for the first decade or so of his life,
he had little in the way of a male role model that he could look up to and learn
from his father.
Ralph Edward was a chief engineer on a tra steamer merchant vessel that had
no schedule and simply went wherever it knee,
either in order to sell or deliver whatever cargo was loaded onto it.
And that had to be difficult.
The elder Chapman would be gone for up to five years at a time making his young
son, the man of the house.
During this time the family lived in Sunland.
It was an area defined by the shipyards and the sea and Chapman grew surrounded
by the hustle ands bustle of shipyards,
scrambling to keep up with the demands made on them by world war.
I, by all accounts Chapman,
the oldest of three siblings was well loved by his brother and sister.
It's a bit of an unconventional start to our tail because family life wasn't too
bad, but that's was only to start with.
Although his father had hoped to see his oldest child following his footsteps,
Chapman had little mechanical am and even less interest in school as Faye would
have it.
This didn't really matter though,
by the time Chapman was a young teenager world war, I was over,
soldiers were returning to the lives that they're left behind as best they
could. And that meant there were a lot of people looking for work.
A recession gripped the country, unemployment skyrocketed. And by 19 30,
19 of the areas,
shipyards had closed the industry street that had been so vital to the country
and to the war efforts just years before was floundering.
And Chapman's father was forced to find other work.
He took on work at a pub where his son helps him serve dock work as sailors and
fishermen. In other words, a pretty rough crowd.
The family still found it nearly impossible to make ends meet.
So young Chapman dropped out of school at just 14 years old.
His intentions were good. He was going to help support his family,
but times were tough and he was only able to find work for a handful of days
every month, what jobs he could find were hard work for little pay.
And in his older years,
Chapman would speak of the slums of his native Sandlands and say they were far
worse than I had seen anywhere else in Europe.
He also added his most lively memories of childhood had been of the cold
misery of the doll in order to claim any benefits.
Chapman was instructed to attend a school where he would learn skills that would
make him more employable. That was the goal, at least. And in hindsight,
that's kind of what happened. He was taught things like working with metal,
but it was hardly productive. It's no under that.
He started skipping classes.
And when he realized his parents had found out about his absences,
he decided to go on something of a walkabout. He tried to go to London.
He tried to find work,
but neither of those things panned out here at return home and ended up being a
surprisingly important in his life had gotten a taste of the adventure that was
out there and it made a lasting impact on him.
This is also when a small but significance event took place.
One that would show that the lifelong duality of Chapman's personality and
motivations went back to when he was a teenager.
It was one Sunday when he and his brother skipped out on going to church,
a major to transgresion with their mother,
they headed to the beach and that's where Chapman had a call for help.
A man was drowning. 50 yards out into the water.
Chapman took off down the beach, dove into the water and saved the man's life.
He never told anyone about it,
at least not until he was honored with a certificate from the role humane
society. He didn't want his mother to know that it's skipped church,
even though he had done something amazing with his day,
it embodied an idea that will continue throughout this tale.
He may do some not so honorable things.
He may have been a scam and a Scally wa without Tony for himself,
but at the end of the day, he did save lives. In spite of all the hardships,
Chapman still had good intentions.
He joins the Coldstream guards when he was just 17 years old with the hell of
osified birthday and a talent for forging his father's signature.
And he excelled at this in spite of a serious knee injury.
He ultimately found himself wearing a God's uniform and he was quite literally
tasked with guarding England's crown jewels at the tower of London,
he'd come a long way, but the old Chapman,
the boy who'd seen the slums witnessed the struggles of the unemployed and the
starving who had elected bottles on the beach to turn in for just a bit of cash
to help his struggling family. That boy was still in there. And in 1933,
he saw something that would change his life. Again, the death of his mother,
he was in the guards when he got the letter and he immediately went to the
tuberculosis ward of a local hospital for the poor.
He made it to her side before she died.
And she did manage to tell him how proud she was of him and how respectable he
looked in his uniform. But he saw something quite different that day.
A wonderful woman who had given her all for her family and who had died in a
hospital for the poor.
And while it doesn't seem to have changed who he was,
it does seem to have been a trigger that changed the path he was on after his
mother's death. He was given leave from the guards. He headed to London,
and that was where he prompted.
He went AWOL predictably Chapman was arrested and sent to the stock aid before
being dishonorably discharged. From there,
it was off to Soho and an entirely different world. Throughout the 1930s,
Chapman was flexing his muscles in the CD underbelly of London in Soho district.
He did everything and anything. He danced, he wrestled,
he forged checks and he was always on the lookout for the chance to knick
something after getting in good with the shady characters who frequented a bar
called smokey Joe's. He escalated into breaking and entering it.
Wasn't long before he got the attention of a group of enemies called the jelly
gang who took their name from the highly explosive material.
They used to break into safes.
The gang led by a man named Jimmy hunt, welcomes him into their ranks.
And it wasn't long before they were blowing off safes and stealing thousands of
pounds from some of the most upscale businesses and retail shops in London.
That kind of thing. It gets attention though.
And the man hunt for the jelly gang came to an end in 1939.
Chapman was first captured in Scotland and managed to escape.
Once his luck run out in Jersey though, and he was arrested and thrown in jail,
and this is where his life takes yet. Another turn while Chapman was busy,
honing his skills in Britain's criminal underworld,
something major was unfolding on the world stage in June of 1940 German forces
invaded the channel islands and set up an occupation that would last until 19.
This meant something far different for Chapman than it did for most of the
British citizens.
Living on the islands control of the islands.
Prisoners was also taken over Chapman. He was now the Germans problem.
He was released in October of 1941. And he,
along with a friends that had made on the inside,
set up a barber shop that catered mainly to the occupying German forces.
This was clever because it was only a barber shop on the surface.
Chapman used his newfound contacts to start buying and selling mostly stolen
goods in his own small corner of the black market.
But it quickly became clear that the Germans weren't as friendly as he might
have hoped Chapman was riding his bike. One day when he was hit by a car,
the accident turned into an interrogation by the German forces and he was given
a warning.
He was to stay out of trouble or else the accident and subsequent questioning
was a very clear indication of just how precarious his position in this German
occupied territory was.
So he decided to take an extra step to secure his own safety.
He wrote a letter to general auto VO NA offering his services in whatever
capacity was needed. The Germans declined to give him a act on.
And a few weeks later he was mysteriously arrested and sent to a prison just
outside of Paris. It probably wasn't the response he was hoping for,
but it wouldn't take long for him to realize that he wasn't headed for jail.
Chapman was held at, for de Roma Ville.
And after he was interrogated by German intelligence, they made him an offer.
They would not only allow him to go free, but return him to Britain.
If he would agree to carry out whatever secret missions the Germans sent him and
not surprisingly, he agreed.
He spent the next three months in training learning espionage and spycraft he
added the use of invisible links and wireless communications to his already
lengthy skillset.
And the German spy masters were so impressed with him that he quickly got his
own code name and designation, Fritz gen V6 5 23. Finally,
it was go time on a chill night in December, 1942,
Chapman parachuted into Cambridge, carrying a radio pistol,
some invisible links, some cash and a cyanide capsule. And from that,
he walked right into a local police station and turned himself in.
It told the little port officers that he had been imprisoned on the channel
islands and then had become a German spy.
And in all fairness,
that had to be an extremely unlikely tale account suggested that he did indeed
have trouble convincing them that he was telling the truth.
But this is where MI five stepped in.
Literally Parker had already intercepted communications regarding his presence
on British soil, and they saw an opportunity.
So they made him another offer work for MI five.
He agreed to do that since it was his British handlers who gave him his most
infamous nickname zigzag under the watchful, I of MI five happened,
radioed his German handler and told him always well,
and that he had made it safely into British territory.
The plan was to go ahead and he was going to blow up the,
to Hava land aircraft factory, putting a damper on the manufacturer,
a fast agile, new mosquito fighter planes. MI five,
of course couldn't allow that to happen.
And Hills where the story crosses into territory.
That sounds more like something.
That's the responsibility of an overzealous screenwriter.
They couldn't blurt the factory,
but they needed to make the Germans think the mission had been a success. So,
well,
how are they gonna pull that off first Chapman's time with the jelly gang had
been useful. It had given him experience with the explosive gel ignite,
which MI five made sure to requisition from a quarrying Kent,
but they weren't going to blow up the whole factory.
They were just gonna create some smoke and mirrors and a little bit of trickery
and make it look as if it had been destroyed.
So the next step was to enlist the help of believe it or not a master magician
and illusionist, his name was Jasper Maline.
And his role in this makes a lot of sense.
Now the onset of the war Maline volunteered in a place where talents could be
put to good use the camouflage development and training center while he was
initially poo booed as not having any legitimate skills.
He was soon transferred to a force,
a unit specializing in deception among his projects were sun shields that would
reflect a light off tanks and make them essentially invisible from the app.
He was also responsible for building a fake city of Alexandria and read
directing German bombers to a fake Sue as canal. His work was so successful.
His name was added to the guapos blacklist and he soon had a bounty placed on
his head, faking the bombing and destruction of one small aircraft factory.
Well, that was probably gonna be Charles's play for him.
Chapman Massel keen and an MI five officer set to work,
small charges were set and part of the factory's roof is destroyed Mascar iron s
et off smoke bombs around the perimeter of the factory scattered pieces of what
looked like debris hung, tar POS camouflage sections of the factory.
And with the help of media coverage detailing the destruction of the factory and
an enthusiastic message from Chapman to his German handlers,
Germany not only bought the story hook line and sinker,
but welcomed Chapman back into the fault.
He had proved himself valuable in 1943. I five sent him on his way.
He hopped on a ship for Lisbon and ultimately ended up in one of the AVEs
Norwegian safe houses. Then he was awarded the iron cross for his success.
And MI five still says,
he's the only British citizen to have been awarded the highest honor.
They didn't approve of the way he spent his downtime,
which mostly involved a lot of drinking and a revolving door of winning.
He was happy enough,
but major Michael ride the MI five agents directly in charge of keeping track of
him. But at blunt Lee,
when he wrote the zigzag case must be closed down at the earliest possible
moment.
But chairman had other ideas.
And as unlikely as it sounds before he headed back into German territory,
he volunteered for a suicide mission.
The success he was believed to have had in destroying the factory,
gave him a certain amount of clout and his German spy master had spoken of the
distinct possibility that he would be treat to a front row seat at one of
Hitler's rallies. Once he returned to Germany,
Chapman's idea was to make good use of his knowledge of explosives and cut the
head off the snake once.
And for all he offered repeatedly. But every time as I five handlers said no,
and because they were familiar with him by now,
they stressed that he was not under any circumstances to try and kill Hitler.
It didn't matter if he, he could get away with it.
If he was willing to die for it, he still wasn't to try. Unfortunately,
all the documents that have been declassified about zigzagged,
his wartime exploits, don't mention just why his superiors were.
So adamants about keeping him from turning into an assassin,
but it's been suggested by historians that there was a very real fear of
reprisals and that by this point in the war Hitler and his erratic behavior was
actually more useful alive than debt,
but there's also a theory that it wasn't Chapman's idea at all,
but that it had been pitched to him by the same spy master who had offered him a
place in the front row of a rally.
Dr. Steven groundman who also went by the name Vaughn groaning had been one of
the men who oversaw Chapman supposed conversation for reveal.
And the word on the street was the it,
he was the one behind Chapman's bid to become imortalized in history as the one
who took out Hitler. Even without that notch on its bells.
Chapman did a decent job of making his own mark on history,
but further word on the street is that he and grin were Kindred's spirits of a
sort Grinman was more than happy to,
to Chapman's horn and sing his praises because it was reportedly skimming a bit
off of Chapman's pay art. Wasn't just going to pay for itself after all.
And he had an asset that he could exploit, ultimately Chapman's plan.
He assassinated LOE was never put into motion and he was sent to Norway there.
He went through more training and among other things fell in love with a
Norwegian woman named Dagmar Lam.
The affair would be one of many wartime flings.
It was another thing he was notorious for during his time under the watch live I
five,
they got so tired of him hooking up with various ladies of the night that they
gave him his own safe house.
And it came compete with a former girlfriend named Frida Stevenson who would
ultimately give birth to their daughter.
If there was one thing that was consistent about zigzag,
it was his love of the ladies,
no matter which side he was currently working for.
And that would change one more time. In 1944,
when his German handler told him that they had another job for him,
Chairman was handed one more assignment from the Germans.
He was to head back to Britain and find out what he could about their abilities
to track German Y boats and to secure whatever technology it was that they were
using in their night flights.
It was also supposed to report back on how successful German bombing raids were
and art parachuting back into England in June,
he and MI five at false information through the German intelligence network,
it was thought to have a very real effect and was credited for diverting
numerous attack. The war was of course, drawn to a close Chapman,
appealed to his handlers and offered to head back to Paris.
But British intelligence declined for a few reasons.
First was that he was high maintenance, unpredictable,
that those that worked with him scenes in decent agreements,
that it was time for his career as a spy to went. Secondly,
am I five already had a slew of information about access plans,
thanks to other agents and their successes in decryption with little Fanta
agents, zigzag was retired from the field.
So what happened to Chapman after the war? Well,
it didn't take long before he tried to capitalize on his adventures,
writing an account of his actions in the war that he tried to serialize in a
French newspaper. Unfortunately for him,
this was in violation of the official secrets act. And he was back in court. He,
to, again, he didn't give up though and published his own story in 1966,
still the official documents remained classified until MI five released them to
the national archive. In 2001,
the decades after the war were filled with enough schemes to fill a book of
their own. He married Betty farm, the former girlfriend,
he had abandoned way back on the channel island of Jersey. They had a daughter,
but he didn't settle down. And neither did.
She both carried on affairs throughout the duration of their relationship.
And it was a very nontraditional,
one Chapman returned to his old ways of buying and selling on the black markets.
He got into protection rackets and even invested in a ship that he used to
further his criminal empire.
He got involved in smuggling once even being smuggled out of 10 years himself by
the 1980,
he had slowed down just a touch and settled into running a health bar in
Hartford chip. He passed away in 1997, at 83 years old.
There's a recurring theme in the opinions of those he worked with,
they believed he was unpredictable fickle and mainly out for himself,
but there's an interesting footnote to the story that suggests he was something
else too like charming. It's difficult to say,
but it is fascinating that he and his German spymaster Dr. Graman remained
friends even beyond the end of the war after the truth came out.
And after all his deceptions,
as a double agent were made public still Graman was at the wedding when
Chapman's daughter got married and that's possibly the most incredible part of
the, so I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
Please do smash that light button if you did. And don't forget to subscribe.
Don't forget to hit the notification bell and as always, I'll see you next time.